my food
I shall
Pleiades so high levels in the father
[Music]
bismillah ar-rahman ar-rahim it's very
lovely to be here in England especially
in this part in Blackburn and I really
enjoyed being with you I wanted to ask
you a lot of folks know who's Yusuf
Estes tell us who you are
my name is Ali Dawa Ali I leave down
yeah now yeah I'm in for real no for
real no for real honey
Ali's not much you're not really here I
feel like I came to this town in 2012
23rd of December I've been involved in
the dowel c4 / / en oh is that right
yeah do you have anything like on
YouTube or anything yes I'm quite like
known in the YouTube with the dowel
scene and so you're famous can I have
your autograph
no no I have a photo with you oh please
you got it but what I really did want to
touch up on is basically I can remember
back in the days I spent about three and
a half years to four years looking into
Islam and basically I used to watch your
videos sake nights video le yes your
videos and having slackers cool yeah
he's a cool guy you know like it's got a
good memory I love it yeah mashallah and
I really used to watch your videos and
snap in here today I just wanted to like
tell the viewers how you know sometimes
we neglect the power of dois
and we say you know what is that really
going to happen but one Allah I'm
standing here today with you and I used
to watch your videos before I came into
Islam yeah
so basically it's just amazing life to
be here with you and obviously I would
really want you advisor because I want
to follow the footsteps of what you do
as a dye and I'll be really good if you
can kind of give me an advice and at the
same time to the views that are watching
who are maybe on the verge of accepting
Islam and a couple of things that you
can maybe touch up on as well well first
and foremost I think what I would tell
you is let's all follow the footsteps of
Muhammad Salla wailing whistling and of
course that's that's implied from the
beginning for the benefit of your
viewers that come to your thing with you
know with not a bad image of Islam or
not the correct ideas would like to just
mention to them that everything in Islam
is always about what the biggest and
foremost of all
things Tarheel islam is what in English
yeah it's in the believe in the oneness
of God Almighty and he has no partners
yeah that's it number one exactly and we
will take that from the hadith of the
Prophet selects alone if I'm not
mistaken it something like this and he
told one of them in trouble I'm sending
you to the people of the book he was on
like him and when you get there teaching
the oneness of God the Tao eatle Islam
and then if they accept that teach them
how to make connection which would be
Salah and if they accept that then teach
them about fasting sound like and go to
everything yeah one by one so this is
what we would do first and foremost
before we talk about newcomers to slim
let's be sure that they are
understanding it is about oneness of God
and most of I think most of your
opposition comes from those who are
either atheists or Christian is it right
yes that's right mostly from Christian
background and hazings backgrounds okay
and who do you see as being more
amenable to your message to take time to
talk with you and foot well to be honest
for the people that are really seeking
the truth they are the ones that really
come like for example we was in Brazil
about a couple of months ago to dude our
in the walk up and those kind of people
they did not know about Islam and they
were very inclined to know and they will
spend a great amount of time like really
listen and why would you know this how
you believe in one God all right so then
those people there in Brazil primarily
you got people there they're Catholic
yes yes majority of them are Catholic we
are for the Catholics we have something
called a website it's called Bible Islam
Bible Islam calm and what we did there
was to take pages and pages from the
Catholic Church itself and then I put
commentary with it to say look at this
this this is what the year for instance
giving one example during the same
century that our Prophet SAW Islam was
propagating Islam which would be the six
hundreds called the seventh century
there was a council convened by the
Catholic
Church for the bishops and Cardinals to
decide whether or not a woman had a soul
when was this what did I just tell you
the same century as Islam came here's
these guys deciding whether or not a
woman has the right to do anything that
she might not even have a soul maybe
she's a shed on or a doubler yeah okay
so you didn't know that yeah another
thing when they talk about the age of
Aisha when she married our prophets
Elijah LOM the eighth Maryam Mary the
mother of Jesus peace be upon him - she
has a baby right but Joseph which is
known to be her husband according to
Christianity is in his 90s and she's
like 13
what about though yeah this is go to the
website and you'll find so many things
especially about the Council of Nicaea
when they actually accepted a form of
paganism that the rebels against them in
the 16th century during 1500s those
people protested against a lot of stuff
that's why they're called protest stunts
okay so you get all of you hila that you
know and I didn't know that I did not
know and they're not gonna stand there
and tell you because they know it'll get
make people start thinking about well
what about this oneness of God would
come back to that okay
look at the Crusades look at the
Inquisition first Crusades and who was
it behind the Crusades pushing so hard
where these were people that were at the
top of the Catholic Church and the
Anglican Church who didn't want people
to hear there's really another religion
out here teaching the same thing that
our prophets taught only without the
paganism Unitarians right if I'm I'm
tell about Muslims oh the Muslims oh yes
yes they don't want people to know that
there is something out here already and
it's a more in line with what you're
reading in your Bible and there be like
especially when you can prove that their
translations are not accurate especially
when they have things that contradict
you within the text and I'll just go the
Hammond on you oh no way but the facts
are facts
the older manuscripts they'll have that
exact where did it come from that's a
puzzle that that one website could help
but you have to let people read it on
their own
don't stand over and tell them you have
to think like this yep then no read
yourself you don't like it throw it away
if you like it okay up to you there's no
compulsion in religion our teachers ah
yeah of course there's no compulsion but
I'm saying that the style methodology
the men Heights the way you approach
somebody you know you better you got to
be fair and you talking to somebody an
intelligent human being who's been lied
to that's all
exactly but you don't want to hear that
his mother lied no his father his
preacher his teacher the people that I
love and care about how could they
possibly lie well they've been lied to
as well yeah that's very true and the
link will be below to your website which
they can check out themselves can I just
ask you a quick question what what was
the main factor that kind of made you
realize that look it's time is the truth
of your other faith that you had before
in a quick summary if you can if you
could summary up to us you know
oftentimes oftentimes when people will
ask me what was it caused you to leave
Jesus to leave Christianity to go to
some religion out here all about
terrorism and bombing and I tell them
okay hold on the two things you just
said are the opposite yeah okay as a
Muslim we are closer to the real Jesus
and we're closer to the way of Jesus
which was to pray to God and we pray to
his God that he told us to pray to yes
you know worship your God and my god
your lord and my lord that's not this
lamb saying that what we haven't in the
Quran but that's coming right out of
Christianity so that's number one number
- when you talk about Islam being about
religion of promoting aggression it
clearly states in Islam that if you
exceed the even forces coming against
you the evil coming against you you're
only allowed to fight back equally but
if you exceed it then you're the
aggressor verily Allah does not love the
aggressor this is found in chapter 2 of
the Quran surah bakra Verte started
verse 189 but you get the feeling over
the promise answering some questions
then go verse 190 he's telling people
about combat first one anyone still on
the same target and then then 193 people
try to take it since force everybody to
be a Muslim it doesn't say that fight or
be in combat until these people cease
and allow you to practice your religion
and tell other people about it that's
the understanding that if a stop
fighting you you were supposed to take
them to a place of security you don't
have that in those verses in the Quran
not on the dose versus okay but the
understanding yeah of course but because
we're not here about trying to take land
away from people we're not here trying
to take rights away from bill what we're
trying to do is make something clear so
you can understand and then if people
are aggressive toward us we're not
allowed to fight them until it becomes
clear combat and then we can only meet
that combat that's what it says in the
verses so have you said why did you
leave Jesus we didn't we're trying to
get closer and why did you leave God
we're trying to get closer to God and
why did you turn back on the Bible well
first of all the Bible you have isn't
the original okay it's a translation and
the Quran is original any quotes the
original Bible because it only came from
God yes or no yes so if the Bible came
from God
the Old Testament was from God says in
the Old Testament that they lost all of
their Scrolls during the Babylonian
occupation so what does that mean they
don't have it anymore they recreated it
fine
but that means it's not the real thing
for Moses Abraham in the previous
prophets you're doing it from memory
fine good I'm sure you got a lot of it
right but it's not gods it's you yes
that's what it says then the same is
true the New Testament you don't really
have what Jesus said you had what people
said that Jesus said take a look at the
beginning of book of Luke and it said it
seems fair to him that everybody else
has got an opinion here he wants to tell
Theophilus about here's how it is in
blah blah blah it's right there in the
beginning of Luke so you understand that
they didn't actually have Jesus on the
spot with a recorder like we've got here
and they didn't really have anything
from his hand that have been written
what we do know from the very oldest
manuscripts is not what they have in
some of their stuff today things were
added over the centuries for
clarification better maybe
beautification to give a better sense of
things but they were added especially
when you want to embellish an opinion
that doesn't really exist there or is
not that clear that for instance that
will take the first book of John one not
John the Apostle
this is John's letter somebody else they
called him John's and in one case they
said they're not even sure it was
somebody named John one two and three
there they followed that that's the only
place in the entire Bible that they can
point to and try to come up with the
Trinity
okay and how they did it was to take a
verse that preceded it and manipulate
the words okay what originally said was
again there's still a translation being
the translation it said there are three
the bear witness which is the father the
blood and the spirit and these three
agree that's what I said they bear
witness now there are three let's share
the same witness I saw a car accident
you saw a car accident he saw a car
accident okay and we agree yeah well
then
another verse there's a take-off on that
say there are three the bear witness in
heaven the Father the Son and the spirit
and these three are one
okay but even then even then it would
have to be there one in agreement
because three doesn't he won one doesn't
equal three alone but that's where they
pulled it from so these kinds of things
are clarified in the Quran so we put our
website out there for there's another
one though where I went into detail
about the Bible now this one for
Protestants is excellent okay and it's
called 911 will be below they can see on
the screen I'm sure they're there by now
hungry laughs well listen Ally it was
great to be with you today
I hope that all of your viewers will
take a chance to come in and and use our
new app yes we have an app it's called
search for Islam's calm okay because
then they can do anything they want to
go to search for and download the app or
if you don't have a that kind of phone
if you got a dumb phone don't have a
smart one you can you can go to the
internet search for slam comm type in a
keyword like oh jihad
Sharia um war terrorism
um wives reading people anything you
want to put in there and then you'll
find tons of stuff you'll find articles
and videos and because we have over
2,500 websites to help people better and
really smell it sibling
Woods what a person that's really takes
time put is on the verge of one step to
PT
there's only one step people ask you
this question
somebody's close to this line what is he
in our only advice to them is this you
can't do it were married you can't do it
for a spouse can't do it 20 can't do it
show off can't good you know gain fame
or no you're doing this for what reason
and if it is sincere and you're doing it
for God and who should you talk to and
you should be alone without anybody
around you bothering you and just saying
in your heart God you guide me and when
a person does that then there's nothing
else you and I can say that's finished
you said I thank you very much like I
said you're gonna cheat on microphone
all right Zak Allah bless you so this is
such a pleasure I can say to you that
I've said it before never in a million
years will be the pleasure we should not
dress to be the power of du'a we can be
on the best you